there's a movement going on at the
moment called pre-order free 2015 which
is encouraged me not to place any
pre-orders this year but should you
let's take a look at what's in a
pre-order and whether it's actually
worth your investment given you never
totally sure what you're going to be
getting out of the game
[Music]
we preorder for a whole bunch of reasons
hype slightly earlier release dates and
pre-order bonuses being among the most
common but are they really good enough
for us to book over a whole bunch of
money for a potentially average game
2014 was a year peppered by broken over
hyped and delayed triple-a titles and a
bunch of those games were ones you could
pre-order and a lot of us did and then
wished we didn't if there's anything
we've learned from 2014 it's that all
the hype and trailers in the world
aren't enough to guarantee the gaming
experience you expect for example
watchdogs not only was I personally
jazzed for watchdogs ever since I
watched the first trailer I bought it in
advance and convinced my dad it was
going to be so amazing that he should
also buy it on day one fast forward to
today and I've only played a couple of
hours my friends who picked it up have
also only played a few hours or opted to
focus on the multiplayer mode instead
before putting the hack tacular
open-world game down indefinitely as far
as games go watchdogs isn't terrible but
a lot of us were made to feel stupid by
working ourselves up into unreasonable
levels of hype and doling out cash
before we understood what we were
actually buying pre-orders are great
furry tail is great for publishers and
downright essential for developers who
want to use Kickstarter but are they any
good for us for retailers pre-orders a
useful so they can get an idea of stock
allocation and demand for games released
as for digital pre-orders on platforms
like Steam stock is a non-issue but you
can usually save a few dollars by opting
to buy before release pre-order bonuses
might be something you're after if
you're really into a certain title but
more often than not you
hang a lot of money based on a guess
that a game will be good I guess which
is probably based on watching trailers
and gameplay demos that are meticulously
crafted by marketing teams to show off
the best parts of the game and hide the
flaws one of the problems with
pre-orders is that people vote with
their wallets so when you put down money
for a game you're essentially saying I
like this thing you made here I have my
money so you can make more things like
this thing for example halo the Master
Chief collection think about the barely
functioning mess it's heavily touted
multiplayer mode was at launch then
think about all the money game is
shelled out on pre-orders based solely
on the good name of Halo those
pre-orders were encouragement saying
that's okay by us and it shouldn't be
once you put money into again you have a
tangible investment and when that
investment is broken at launch it should
be a huge turnoff to pre-order in future
whether you've been burned by driveclub
SimCity or Diablo we've learned the hard
way that always online functionality is
not always easy to implement fortunately
you don't need to be the guinea pig
dealing with a game that just won't work
at launch by the same logic you also
don't need to be coaxed in by preorder
exclusives take a bulb for example a
game that wants to give you instant
access to unlockable characters for
putting your dollars down early
depending on where you pre-order from
personally I'd rather read the reviews
by it if I'm into it and then play the
game to unlock the characters then I'll
buy DLC if I'm really into it what also
creates an issue with when pre-order
bonuses feature exclusive add-on content
this exclusive pre-order only content is
designed to make you feel like you have
to buy that version for the bonus
missions or characters by doing so
however you're encouraging publishers to
see that if they lock game is out of
content from the main game only to let
them back in with a pre-order they'll be
rewarded without dollars but think about
it has there ever really been a case
where pre-order exclusive content that
you really wanted
hasn't been made available later down
the line now this video isn't to say
that any of last year's games which
stumbled upon release were all bad and
I'm not suggesting that evolve or any of
this year's upcoming games won't be any
good but unless you're desperate for
those pre-order bonuses or super sure
about that title and want to save a few
dollars by buying digitally it's hard to
find a good reason to fork over your
money early before you know what you're
in for
well unless you're really into
collecting statuettes and remote control
robots let me know what you think do you
typically pre-order games you want have
you ever majorly regretted a pre-order
and what do you think of pre-order free
2015 share your experiences with us and
I will catch you again soon
[Music]